we got some things going I never
understood the Rock Nation thing because
I always like thought to myself like
it's not like you Lake and Don Cannon
aren't of the culture
who the [__] you are say it again so I
was like yo say it again why aren't why
is it Roc Nation trying to pull people
out of deals from like actual culture
vultures say it again DJ Drama like like
you're trying to [__] pull my guy out
of like like he's like he found this kid
you know what I'm saying like DJ Drama
did not pay bootleg Kev to make such an
accurate statement no as soon as that
happened I was like
there's people who you should Advocate
to get out of deals say it again but
we're talking about Don Cannon drama and
Lake come on bro like
three young black successful
men who met in college at the ages of 18
and 19
hbcus by the way and made a name for
themselves within the hip-hop culture
for two decades Paving the way and
putting on and providing for the culture
like huh yeah of anybody that should
have been embraced or it should have the
the way it played out that like I didn't
see them advocating to like get at uh
Meek Mill released off at Atlantic after
he complained about how he didn't like
his deal right all right
anyway shout out to Uzi he's a [__]
Legend absolutely how's the pink tape
sounding it's dope yeah yeah it's a lot
of songs I know they're trying to you
know get them down to a like a good
solid
I don't want to say a number but
um they got a lot of music they got a
lot of music so you uh making this
Proclamation that just went to rock is
the New Philly Anthem I think only would
have actually worked out if you guys won
the Super Bowl it [__] me up when we
lost and I um it [__] me up because I
booked you that night I was like we got
drama we about to have the eagle
celebration party let's go [__] it oh
man [__] Patrick Mahomes and his boy
that I put my foot in my mouth on that
one but everybody keeps leaving out I
said this year like I said this year but
um yeah that that was a viral moment
yeah uh that was fun what did you see in
like first of all how did you actually
find Jack Harlow because all these like
old videos of him being 12 and rapping
like went viral like like a year or two
ago and it was just so funny oh this
little [__] was rapping when he
was a child yeah how did you like
actually like discover a kid a little
white dude by all means kind of a little
nerdy dude in in Louisville so I had a
homeboy come to the studio one day and
just say his name to me
and I went on Instagram and just like
immediately followed him and Jack saw me
follow him and he like filed me back and
he wound up later telling me like he
told his homeboy like yo DJ Drama just
followed me like Damn signed the drum
and there's a very legendary engineer
that we've worked with
um throughout my career who's uh mixed a
bunch of my records as well as a lot of
Classics including Dreams and Nightmares
worked with Waka worked with um Two
Chains his name is ky ky engineering so
yeah he has you know KY engineering
legendary tag yeah so his name is ky
because he's from Kentucky and
um around the same time that I had found
out about Jack he was also uh working
with Jack and he told Lake like yo I got
something I want to bring to you you
know I just want to get it to a certain
space so he was you know he was putting
a bug in Lakes ear about Jack so it kind
of like literally happened around the
same time and then Jack just one one day
found his way to main streets and then
you know I heard he was in the building
and we like we met we sat down and we
chopped it up we talked music and life
and movies and [__] like that and and
you know I was I was just impressed and
then you know we came to the table like
you know we had a meeting and uh all
parties you know came to the agreement
that we want to design them it's crazy
too because I do feel like you guys have
kind of gone the old school route of
like actually developing artists yeah
that's how we like to do it we like to
get
involved like in the early stage of the
their career and like you know be part
of artist development